[Musique]
une situation tendue dans les stations
services mais aussi dans les transports
mardi une journée de grève
interprofessionnelle se tenait à l'appel
de plusieurs syndicats des perturbations
dans les services publics notamment côté
rail le RER C les lignes du Transilien
jlnu ont été très impactés dans les
Yvelines
rassembler l'ensemble des acteurs
startup innovantes PME ou grands groupes
pour présenter et mettre en situation
des solutions de sécurité informatique
l'objectif d'horizon cyber grand
rendez-vous autour de la cybersécurité
qui était au programme à l'ESTACA un
thème d'actualité alors que des
collectivités ont été visées par des
cyber-attaques première pierre
symbolique posée le chantier du futur
campus de l'innovation mine Paris PSL
est lancé sur le plateau de satori à
Versailles c'est locaux accueilleront
fin 2024 trois laboratoires de pointe
750 personnes dont 300 chercheurs le
département des Yvelines a investi 38
millions d'euros dans ce projet top
départ des championnats du monde de Para
cyclisme sur piste jusqu'à dimanche 230
athlètes de 39 délégations s'affrontent
au Vélodrome national un événement de
préparation en vue des Jeux
paralympiques de Paris 2024 16 titres
sont décernés et puis la parcouru 250 km
à travers toute l'île de France le
périple de Xavier Thévenard l'ultra
trailer s'achève ce vendredi il a
sensibilité à la pratique sportive et
correspondables
[Musique]